Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Cuando era chico, tan chico que
no llegaba ni a la tecla de la luz,
pensaba que amigo era sinónimo de Mateo,
mi vecino que vivía
a media cuadra de casa.
Con él prácticamente nos criamos juntos
y nunca hizo falta "hacernos amigos"
porque nuestra amistad era
un hecho más de la naturaleza.
Como que el cielo es azul
o que eso que escuchábamos
en la radio a pilas
en el medio de la noche en el bosque
eran señales de extraterrestres
o de astronautas en apuros.
Y durante mucho tiempo pensé
que no había otras personas
allá afuera además de Mateo
con las que yo pudiera
compartir mis intereses.
Cuando empecé el colegio mis compañeritos
se me acercaban en el recreo,
me hacían alguna pregunta,
yo les respondía,
daba media vuelta, y seguía con lo mío.
La directora veía esto
y le parecía como que yo me escapaba
cuando las personas se me acercaban.
Pero no lo hacía a propósito.
En algún momento
se me acercó la directora,
que además era mi mamá,
y me explicó que a veces
las personas nos hacen preguntas
no tanto porque
quieren saber la respuesta
sino porque quieren conversar.
A esa altura ya era obvio
que había muchas cosas
que yo no entendía cómo funcionaban.
Por ejemplo, cuando mis vecinos
más grandes jugaban a las escondidas
yo iba y les marcaba uno por uno
dónde se habían escondido.
Entonces se enojaban, y se quejaban,
y yo explicaba
que si unos se habían escondido
y otros los estaban buscando
y yo sabía dónde se habían escondido
por qué no podía ir,
contarles dónde estaban,
y resolver toda la situación.
O en los cumpleaños.
Yo llevaba el regalo
y, justo antes de entregarlo,
lo abría y explicaba de qué se trataba,
dónde lo habíamos comprado,
cuánto había salido
y si estaba o no de oferta.
Me costaba horrores no salir corriendo
a contarle a todo el mundo
cada vez que aprendía algo nuevo.
Y en esas situaciones
también me daba cuenta
de que a veces a las personas
el mundo se nos hace demasiado complejo
y quizás no nos preguntamos lo suficiente.
Hace ya algún tiempo que me doy cuenta
de que cuando me explican algo social
lo puedo desarmar como si fuera una cosa
de las que tenemos a nuestro alrededor,
con cables y tornillos y tuercas.
Pero que, por ejemplo,
cómo funcionan los cumpleaños
o cómo funciona hacer amigos,
o cómo funciona jugar a las escondidas
son cosas que también
se puede entender cuando las abrimos.
Por eso es que ya
desde hace bastante tiempo
cuando me preguntan de qué trabajo
cuento que me dedico a entender
cómo funcionan las cosas.
Es una respuesta un poco pretenciosa.
Entonces algunas personas
piensan que me dedico a esto
porque soy una especie
de experto en cosas,
con una peculiar capacidad
para entender cómo es que funcionan.
Lo cierto es que si me dedico a esto
es porque me cuesta mucho
pero mucho entender
qué demonios pasa a mi alrededor.
Y eso siempre me hizo sentir
como una especie de bicho raro.
Porque me daba cuenta de que
no solo hacía muchas preguntas,
y más que las personas a mi alrededor,
sino que por lo general
mis preguntas eran distintas.
Y así por ejemplo aprendí que
cuando alguien dice "me muero de hambre"
no hace falta llamar a una ambulancia.
O que cuando alguien nos cuenta
que se le murió un familiar
lo mejor no es alegrarnos,
incluso si esa persona ahora
va a tener más tiempo libre.
Y haciendo muchas preguntas
también me di cuenta de que las personas
por lo general no se preguntan
acerca de las cosas más normales,
de las cuestiones cotidianas.
Por ejemplo, ¿por qué nos saludamos
con un beso o nos damos la mano?
Al menos, solíamos hacer eso.
O ¿por qué a veces las personas
nos preguntan cómo estás
aunque no les interesa
realmente nuestra respuesta?
O ¿por qué las personas
compran y llevan ramos
de las estructuras reproductivas
características de las
plantas espermatofitas
-- flores --
y se las dan a una persona
que no se siente bien,
o como una forma de seducción
de la persona que les gusta?
Y cuando hacés muchas preguntas
también te das cuenta
de que a veces a las personas
no les cae muy bien.
Entonces algunas se enojan
porque quizá se dan cuenta
de que nunca habían pensado
en algunas cosas.
Y hay otras que se frustran
porque se dan cuenta
de que quizás no sabían tanto
ni entendían tanto como creían.
No tengo un truco especial
para hacerme muchas preguntas.
Lo único que hago es prestar atención
en particular a la voz de mi curiosidad.
Que es esa vocecita que cuando
somos chicos nos atosiga con preguntas
y es la que nos invita a preguntar
"¿Y por qué?" cada dos preguntas.
Y es esa que,
a medida que vamos creciendo,
nos vamos acostumbrando a ignorar.
A veces porque no encontramos
a quién hacerle alguna pregunta.
Y a veces porque después de preguntar
mucho la otra persona se cansa
y nos dice "Porque sí".
Y nos manda a jugar al patio.
No olvidemos que algunas personas
logran ignorar su vocecita
y seguir sus vidas sin nunca
levantarse a las 2 de la mañana
para buscar algo en Internet.
Pero para algunas otras personas
nuestra voz es tan insistente
que, si la tratamos de acallar,
llora y patalea toda la noche
y no nos deja dormir.
La forma que yo encontré de hacer
las paces con la voz de mi curiosidad
es justamente prestarle mucha atención.
Y desde hace tres años
y medio no solo persigo mi curiosidad
sino documentarlo una vez por semana.
Todos los domingos a la mañana
envío por correo electrónico
un texto breve acerca
de cómo funciona una cosa distinta.
Y me fijo lo que dijo la ciencia,
la filosofía, la historia o la literatura
acerca de algo que haya llamado
mi atención durante la semana.
Por ejemplo, escribí acerca
de cómo funcionan los bolsillos.
A veces no son más que
un mero reflejo de la manera
en que la misoginia o el sexismo
toman la forma de diminutos bolsillitos
que no sirven para nada.
O cómo funciona
tener una identidad secreta.
Que nos permite explicar por qué a veces
cuando nos ponemos
unos anteojos o un buzo
o incluso una capa nos podemos sentir
más seguros de quiénes somos.
O es lo que permite explicar
por qué nunca nos vieron a Batman
y a mí en el mismo lugar.
O cómo funciona bostezar,
que es un comportamiento involuntario
que traemos en nuestra historia evolutiva
desde hace muchísimo tiempo
y que prácticamente nos conecta
con todo el resto de vertebrados
en el planeta Tierra.
O, en otras palabras,
es la respuesta a la pregunta
que nunca nadie se hizo
respecto de qué tienen en común
una lagartija, un pingüino y Brad Pitt.
Y así ya llevo 150 correos escritos,
o un poco más.
Pero, sobre lo que más me gusta escribir
es acerca de esas cosas
absolutamente cotidianas
de las que a las personas ni siquiera
se les ocurre buscar nada al respecto.
Cosas como mirar a los ojos,
o dar un abrazo,
o darle un beso o agarrarle
la mano a la persona que te gusta.
O empezar una conversación
o incluso hacer nuevos amigos.
Y durante mucho tiempo pensé
que todo el mundo entendía
cómo funcionaban esas cosas.
Y que el día que lo habían explicado
yo me había quedado en casa con varicela.
Pero ahora que soy más grande y más pillo
me doy cuenta de que en realidad
la mayoría de las personas
no entienden muy bien
cómo funcionan las cosas.
Y no solo eso sino que muchas veces
ni siquiera se hacen muchas preguntas.
Quizás es porque da un poco de alergia
hacer tantas preguntas.
O quizás es porque nos acostumbramos
a que dispersarse y perseguir
nuestra curiosidad está mal.
Y que es mejor saber más de menos y menos
que saber más de más y más.
Y también aprendí que algunas personas
solo necesitan un empujoncito
para empezar a hacerse preguntas
y detenerse en las cosas que
le llamaron la atención durante la semana.
Eso sí, no deja de ser
especialmente extraño
estar acá hablando
acerca de la curiosidad
o de hacerse muchas preguntas.
Y es interesante que
cuando empecé a escribir
lo hice porque me sentía un poco solo.
Porque puede ser un poco solitario
hacernos muchos preguntas
y tratar de buscar esas respuestas
y luego querer compartirlo con el mundo.
Pero encontré que somos
un montón de bichos raros
y que hay miles de personas que leen,
que cuando su curiosidad
no les deja dormir
la invitan a un pijama party.
Y nada de esto debería sonarnos novedoso
porque, de hecho, haciéndonos preguntas
es que surgió la filosofía
o la ciencia o incluso la poesía.
Y es en la búsqueda de las respuestas
en las distintas disciplinas
que no encontramos más que poesía.
Y alguien me podría decir,
bueno, muy bien,
pero la curiosidad no sirve para nada.
Porque si lo que queremos
es tener un mejor trabajo
o ganar una beca o aprobar una materia
lo que más nos conviene
es enfocarnos lo más posible
y dispersarnos lo menos posible.
Y eso es absolutamente cierto.
Pero al mismo tiempo si nos fijamos
de dónde vienen las buenas ideas
encontramos que vienen de unir cosas
que estaban muy distantes entre sí
y cuya relación ni se nos ocurría
y que tampoco eran tan obvias.
Y es por eso que
si no nos hacemos preguntas
nuestro mundo se hace
cada vez más chiquitito.
Y eso es especialmente trágico.
Sobre todo porque también,
si nos detenemos a pensar un poco,
somos la única especie que tiene
esta capacidad de pensarse a sí misma
y de pensarse en relación al universo,
y en las respuestas maravillarse.
Por eso es que además de todo tenemos
cierto deber moral de asombrarnos.
Y en esta eterna búsqueda de no solo
las cosas que nos llaman la atención
sino también de sentirnos menos solos
quizá la respuesta
está también en esas instancias
en que en el recreo alguien
se me acercaba a hacer alguna pregunta
y yo me daba media vuelta y me iba.
Y quizá la respuesta es justamente
que cuando nos preguntan algo
seguir haciendo preguntas.
Y la clave no sea más que esa:
Nunca dejar de hacernos preguntas.